[Music]  a group of golden retrievers arriving in  las vegas tonight after being saved from  being slaughtered overseas it feels  great to save them and to give them to  loving homes because goldens without  goldens  are lovers you know that they'll hug  they're gentle  in all 12 dogs making it to the valley  tonight they were rescued from china  earlier this year and brought to canada  where they've been in quarantine for six  months yesterday they were released in  local organization goldings without  borders made that long drive from  vancouver to get them here seven of them  are available for adoption we have a  link to do that with the group on our  website eightnewsnow.com